if you've ever worked in a corporate
setting before corporate jargon is a
familiar hated fact of life stuff like
this can be pretty frustrating our
company has a new strategic initiative
to increase market penetration maximized
and it's easy to wonder if there isn't a
simpler way to communicate at work and
it seems like the higher up in the
corporate ladder you go the worse the
jargon gets managers are perhaps the
most notorious for this and I'm not
criticizing technical jargon which is
necessary to describe specific details
in every industry I'm criticizing fluff
jargon corporate speak the kind of vague
lexicon that makes up so much of office
working life it isn't just inefficient
it allows for confusion and corruption
to hide in plain sight
look there are valid reasons to say this
keep things high-level and go after the
low-hanging fruit but there aren't that
many reasons sometimes it's to soften
bad news we're restructuring an
optimizing capital location sounds a lot
better than we're firing people you're a
great candidate with a lot of exciting
prospects is a better intro to a job
rejection letter than the truth you
weren't qualified enough other times
it's to sound more professional let's
double down on our 8020 operations it
sounds a lot more respectable than let's
do more of the stuff that makes us money
these are all legitimate ways to use
corporate jargon but mashed together too
much corporate speak and it can render
speech and writing all but
incomprehensible in fact as a testament
to this Andrew Davidson made a corporate
lingo generator online that spits out
professional sounding gibberish for
example we have robust networks of
strategic assets that we own or have
contractual access to which give us
greater flexibility and speed to
reliably deliver widespread logistical
solutions we have metamorphosed from an
asset based pipeline and power
generating company to a marketing and
logistic company whose biggest assets
are its well-established business
approach and innovative people and this
is exactly where corporate lingo and
jargon has a dark side it allows people
to hide things in plain sight without
anyone noticing as I read that randomly
generated statement full of jargon your
eyes probably glazed over a little you
probably didn't pay that close of
attention and that's exactly what the
people writing or saying these things
want or expect they are designed that
way in fact what I just read wasn't from
Andrew Davidson sites at all it was Jeff
Skilling's final letter to the in Ron
shareholders reassuring them that
everything was
fine you know right before it went under
as one of the most blatant and
fraudulent companies of the decade and
it isn't just used in business in this
clip Jack Abramoff an infamous lobbyist
in Washington reflects on some of the
tricks of language he used to get things
done for his clients what we did was we
crafted language that was so obscure so
confusing
so uninformative but so precise to
change the US code here's what you tried
to get tacked on to this Reform Bill
public law 189 is amended by striking
section 207 paren 101 stat period 668
commas 672 close paren right now isn't
that obvious what that means
so that's what you tried to get inserted
yes and that was gonna provide for a
casino yes and who on earth is gonna
know that no one except the chairman of
the committee's and it was deliberately
written like that precisely precisely
that's what's so interesting about this
the word choice is precise the meaning
intentionally vague sometimes pages of
documents are dedicated to hiding one
message within the white noise of
platitudes that's the old you didn't
read the fine print trope in movies like
the social network and it's how people
get Zuckerberg interestingly the noise
of corporate jargon is measurable in
1946 a man named dr. Rudolf Flesch
designed a formula to calculate how
easily understood something is it's
called the flesh readability score the
higher the score the easier to read and
comprehend the lower the score the more
difficult it is just a few landmarks to
think about newspaper comics score to 93
Sports Illustrated at 63 The Wall Street
Journal 43 and the IRS tax code the holy
book of confusing corporate jargon comes
in at an impressive negative six now
obviously there are complex ideas that
can never be expressed with a 90 plus
readability score but most complex ideas
can be expressed in the 30 to 50 range
which is considered to be difficult
reading below 30 the flesh formula
considers the document to be very
confusing now let's get back to
corruption in the book why
businesspeople speak like idiots the
authors use this flesh readability test
to analyze the shareholder letters from
CEOs at the turn of the sin
they analyzed a set of well-respected
companies and a set of companies that
have been riddled with scandal as it
turns out the admired companies all have
letters in the 40 range of readability
while the companies that had scandals
all had much more confusing letters
coming in at the 20s and below and
that's because the companies with
scandals have every incentive to be very
confusing and used vague jargon to do it
while a company that has legitimate
business practices has every reason to
be forthcoming okay now obviously not
all confusing jargon is meant to hide
corruption but when there is corruption
to hide corporate language is a great
way to do it you can say a lot without
saying anything at all or say everything
while making it sound like nothing so
let's stop circumventing the normally
understood value-added lexicon with
derivative proxies and instead talk
normally by the way if you're interested
there's a political movement called the
plain language movement who have voiced
a lot of the concerns you heard in this
video you can check out their website in
the description below
[Music]